tras el levantamiento del título 42
algunas migrantes venezolanas cuentan su
difícil experiencia de vida en Estados
Unidos cuestionan El sueño americano y
piden a las autoridades en Washington
condiciones de vida dignas esta mujer de
las costas venezolanas que no da su
nombre por seguridad al llegar a
Washington ubicada en un hotel
abandonado que reabrió para acoger
migrantes pero reclama que las
condiciones de vida son precarias bueno
en cuanto a la alimentación no es digna
para un ser humano ni para un adulto ni
para un niño y en cuanto las camas Bueno
ya son como camas ya muy obsoletas y en
cuanto la parte de la higiene con las
sábanas y los paños no es la adecuada
al menos 12,000 migrantes han sido
enviados en autobuses desde Texas y
Arizona a Washington y según la oficina
de Servicios al migrante la ciudad no
tiene más albergues para recibirlos esta
otra venezolana que viajó desde Ecuador
pide una identificación para
independizarse y dejar de ser una carga
en realidad el que quiere trabajar Busca
manera de hacerlo como sea y nosotros
los venezolanos pues Considero que somos
bastantes guerreros y no nos paramos por
algo como eso pero si sería de bastante
ayuda porque quizás podríamos optar a
mejores sueldos pues para Diana
organizadora comunitaria de la ong
la falta de papeles de los migrantes se
hace que algunas empresas se aprovechen
de ellos
de robo de salario
Lo escucho todos los días y es otra cosa
que queremos trabajar también porque así
las personas no tengan documentos para
trabajar
Ellos tienen derechos y si los contratan
para trabajar tienen que pagarles lo
justo Estas mujeres quieren seguir
trabajando hasta lograr una vida digna e
independiente pero están lejos porque
siguen en manos de las autoridades
locales